[Music]  i want to talk to you about your  association  the ftth council of europe  whether you work for an operator a  technology provider  or an investor your company has joined  the council to help you get the most  out of the incredible business  opportunities created by the development  of  full fiber networks in europe on october  20th  we will all gather online for our autumn  general  assembly every employee of a 160 members  can attend you will learn how to get  more value for your membership  and you will have your say about the  future  of the ftth council don't miss this  opportunity  register now and forward this message  to your colleagues thank you